Personality,
all your lectures are available on,
on Youtube and,
and you can either watch them as a whole or you can see bits and pieces.
And this is in part what has made you world famous and Cain to tremendous
support.
And those videos,
they seem to be full of all sorts of coaching advices from raising children to
really,
really relationship advice is being a good person and facing all sorts of
challenges.
Can you talk a little bit about these two courses?
A little bit about the maps of meaning course is based on a book I wrote,
which was my first book called maps of meaning,
which is coming out in audio form on June 12th.
It's a very difficult book,
I would say.
I wrote it not so much to communicate,
let's say with the general public,
but to solve a,
to address and attempt to solve a very complex problem.
And I was curious about why the world had found itself in a stalemate after
World War II with the Soviet bloc and the western block say arming themselves
ever more insanely,
um,
in this ideological deadlock.
And I was curious about why the belief systems that we were each,
that each side was putting forward,
we're so seemed so important that it was worth risking the world itself to
support them.
And so maps of meaning is an inquiry into the purpose of belief systems and more
than that it goes down to the individual.
Yes.
Well that's the thing.
Is that
what,
what I,
what I came to understand,
I think was that the,
the proper way forward,
the proper way of conceptualizing the world is one that's individual centered
now.
And I was curious about that because of course the Soviet view was a
collectivist view and you can make a strong case for a collectivist view and it
might be that either view,
the individualist view or the collective view is arbitrary in some sense.
But I don't believe that the view that privileges the individual over the state
is arbitrary.
I think that it's correct and correct.
Meaning that if you act it out in the world at the individual level or the
family level or the or the societal level,
that it produces societies that are functional and healthy and productive and
safe and secure and free in the medium to longterm.
I think that it's,
and then I tried to lay out the psychological reasons for the development of the
idea of sovereign individual and to show that that was grounded in more than
arbitrary ideology.
And so maps of meaning the course,
which that's been a very popular course.
I taught that at Harvard for six years and then at the University of Toronto
ever since.
And it's generally regarded as a course that changes people's lives.
So many of your students say that.
Yes,
it's very,
it's very common response.
And so why,
why do you think that is?
How has it changed the students?
Well,
we have a,
we have a lot of explicit thoughts that we can articulate,
but they're grounded in,
in other forms of thinking.
They're grounded in images and artistic expression and narratives.
So we're fundamentally grounded in the world inside stories and maps of meaning
is an attempt to lay out the structure of those stories and to say,
look,
here's how the world is composed.
It's composed of chaos and order,
which is a strange way of looking at it.
And on top of that,
there's a,
an ethical struggle which has been formulated most typically as a battle between
good and evil.
And I think that that's the right way of looking at the world is that human
beings are engaged in this struggle between good and evil on a background of
chaos and order.
And maps of meaning is an attempt to explain what those categories mean in terms
that you can grip and then and that you can use.
Conceptually,
I'm practically in the world.
So it's not merely a high level abstract discussion,
although it is that in part,
it's an attempt to take that high level abstract discussion and say,
here's why.
If you know that you will be able to operate more effectively in the world.
And I think that once you know these categories,
you can operate more effectively in the world.
It strengthens your resilience in the face of catastrophe,
for example.
It's encouraging it.
It helps reestablish the dignity of the individual and to describe why that's a
real thing and the most real thing even.
And so it's very salutary for people because everyone doubts the utility.
People doubt their own value.
That's probably the most precise way of putting it.
And there are reasons that you shouldn't doubt your value.
They're deep reasons.
And so maps of meaning lays that out.
It was those one thing that
grabbed me.
He will talk.
Talking about what,
what sort of push when you want to be,
when,
uh,
when you went in the face of,
of maybe a death in the family.
Um,
can you elaborate on one of the things?
Well,
you know,
many
people,
it's not easy for people to determine what their goals should be in our culture
because our culture is,
I would say materialistic and,
and there's some positive things about that,
but so much in its ethical orientation.
And so we think,
well,
people should strive to be happy.
And I think that that's a weak aim.
Not that there's anything wrong with being happy if,
if it happens,
great,
but it's a side effect of something else.
I see.
It's not a goal in and of itself.
The a better goal is to be courageous and resilient and strong and one of the,
but that's a taboo today so much it's because people don't understand it well.
Like I've told my students that they should try to beat the strongest person at
their father's funeral.
That's a,
because you are going to face tremendous adversity in your life and you need to
think through what sort of person you want to be under conditions of adversity
and a funeral is a very good example of that because it's a catastrophe for
everyone involved and someone has to bear the responsibility to navigate the,
the ship of the family through the storms of the death.
And if you think about a person that can do that,
obviously such a person is admirable and there's every reason to set your goal
as the development of an admirable character.
Something else we don't talk about anymore.
It's as if the whole idea of admirable character has been dispensed with,
and I think that's associated with the idea,
at least in part of the [inaudible] patriarchy,
you know,
if our culture is nothing but a tyrannical patriarchy,
which it is most decidedly not,
then anyone who takes forthright action in that structure is nothing but a
patriarchal tyrant.
It's like none of that is reasonable.
So this is a really negative,
not active,
this whole patriarchy idea.
It's a terrible narrative.
It,
and I think the purpose of the narrative is,
is fundamentally to blur the distinction between competence and power.